that's it that's it I'm supposing your
rich when I open this it's pretty I'll
give it that
that's a beautiful liquid I don't drink
very often but when I do
champagnes worth I think champagne is
made by fairies
I haven't had champagne in hours I feel
like a good champagne should be really
light and crisp and should be just it
sounds a little too like pea yellowy for
me it's got a little stank on it more
stank the more expensive it is I don't
know I don't I don't know we're ready
now how much we think it is 15 43
anything cost that I think I might have
overshot is $80 no no
everyone drink Hey
whoa that's delightful yeah this is like
what you putting out to your ladies
night book club it's definitely fruitier
than the other one all of them $35 a
bottle there's a lot of bubbles and thus
I think it's about a medium price
champagne I'm gonna say $17.99 got it
exactly right yeah the price is right
you get like $500 you know when you eat
like live octopus know when you eat live
octopus it like bites at you you know
cuz like you're just you're both like
Kwan and nature's like eating each other
this is mimosa champagne that's what
this is what you pour into orange juice
if this is expensive I'm leaving I'm a
simple boy if I like something it's
probably cheap and if I hate something
is probably experiencing it's got to be
over 9000
I've always pronounced it Cougs this has
bailed me in every way this is the size
of my face Cheers
last one y'all that one's the one we're
like you put in your egg goes your mouth
you chew scope but I should be good with
apple juice in it oh that's dangerous
man once you add juice you're gonna down
that like you're damn right I will
I'm gonna win this round
Santa's a $75 champagne I'm gonna go at
$29.99 I think this is like in the
middle of the road 8:59 fell Geils a
pretty weak champagne don't think that
one where you were over uh today we
tasted a couple different kinds of
champagne I still think champagne is
made by fairies I feel wonderful we did
what my good friend 50-cent would call a
champagne campaign